dias mais ça ne pose pas trop de 11
maisons lès laumes un peu un bon thé à 8
points
tu étais choisi cartonne j'en suis
toujours convaincu chacun doit être
sauvée levé les mains en l'air et dit
'alleluia' dit je suis un soldat gilat
je partirai en plus est heureux parce
que je sais déjà que tu seras là pour
quitter les fidèles
[Musique]
ça concerne également les gens avec qui
j'ai grandi il se soit éloigné du droit
chemin
tu me croit quand je te dis que dieu
veut parler
qu'est ce que ça peut faire ce que tous
les autres croate à dire c'est important
pour moi
mon cher
mais m
j'entends dire que j'ai arrêté de croire
à l'enfer et j'ai entendu une voix
chaque être humain a déjà été sonore
vous ne pouvez pas à réécrire la becque
j'aimerais écrire lire je ne fais que la
lyre vous transmettez la parole de dieu
dans cette église notre dieu aime chacun
de nous pourquoi tu m'as pas appeler un
tu crois pas que tu me devais ça
je repose la question tu dois réfléchir
à toutes les choses qui sont en jeu pour
toi mais aussi pour son combat en toi tu
m'as pas besoin d'être sauvé quand
sérieux tu peux pas le savoir
tu veux une preuve que c'était par la
voix de dieu la moitié de ses filiales a
quitté l'église
ça suffit
tu es avec moi où tu ne mets pas vous
venez nous dire que nous avons tort et
que vous avez raison c'est une doctrine
mensongère que vous battiez
[Musique]
es-tu certaine que c'est la voie du
seigneur que tu as entendu
[Musique]
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
suis aussi surtout quoi et je ne vais
pas abandonner
[Musique]